die stimmung ist hier keinesfalls
gestiegen natürlich man hat hier in
wilmington delaware einen rausch eine
rauschende sieger rede eigentlich
erwartet von joe biden das wurde auch
hier so konzipiert man hat ja eine
riesige dort drüben eine riesige bühne
zusammengezimmert einen parkplatz frei
gemacht das sollte neben 300 autos
vorfahren mit den fans drinnen das hat
man auch aus dem wahlkampf gesehen
dieses so genannten drive in events das
war ebenso beides antwort auf die korona
virus pandemie und leider eben für die
beiden anhänger ist die stimmung hier
nicht besonders einige haben hier das
areal bereits verlassen unklar ist
eigentlich ob es überhaupt zu einer rede
kommen wird von joe biden in den
nächsten stunden es hat allerdings in
den letzten minuten geheißen dass doch
die autos wieder auf dem parkplatz
vorfahren sollen also eine gewisse
ungewissheit die hier herrscht und ich
bin hier mit einer beiden anhängerin
namens kelly kelly geht es gut danke du
bist heute mit großer hoffnung mehr
gekostet
etwas enttäuscht richtig ja auf jeden
fall ich bin enttäuscht aber ich bin
weiterhin optimistisch dass joe biden
das immer noch schaffen können zusammen
mit kamera harris ich bin trotzdem
enttäuscht ich finde von unserem land
enttäuscht
ich dachte wir senden der welt einem
nachricht heute abend bis auch
enttäuscht dass wir die art und weise
wie joe biden seine kampagne geführt hat
viele haben kritisiert dass er nicht
genug getan um die welt er war sich zu
sicher dass er gewinnen würde fühlst du
denkst du dass ich denke es gibt da eine
gratwanderung
aufgrund des corona virus und der
maßnahmen ich werde nie wieder einer
umfrage vertrauen können dass es
natürlich sehr schade da kann man
einfach nicht sicher sein
dass man den ergebnissen vertrauen kann
dass das dann am ende wirklich die
stimmen sein werden aus dieser
perspektive hoffe ich hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass die kampagne größer
gewesen wäre dass da mehr passiert wäre
hatte andere art und weise von kontakt
zu wählern und wählerinnen es war
natürlich schwierig aufgrund des wiso
selber wenn man sich das noch mal
anschaut dann hätten wir da einen
entscheidenden sieg herausholen
wahrscheinlich wird es heute abend noch
keinen sieger geben es wird
wahrscheinlich noch mal erzählt und da
gibt es eventuell sogar noch rechtliche
weitere schritte hast du angst ich habe
etwas angst um die zukunft unseres
landes aber nicht aufgrund von gewalt
ich denke es gibt natürlich spannungen
im lande aber ich habe angst dass unser
land eine nachricht sendet die die welt
und an diejenigen die in einer
minderheit sind und dann das sind dazu
führen wird dass unser land kennt
wirklich um die zukunft amerikas und
auch das bild amerikas in der welt sie
sagt ja auch dass sie doch ein wenig
enttäuscht ist
sie glaubt dass die beiden vielleicht
mehr hätte tun können während diesen
wahlkampf ist dass er allerdings eine
feine einen spagat praktisch marschieren
musste um zwischen krone virus pandemie
und wahlkampf hier abzuwägen aber
insgesamt natürlich eine ganz andere
stimmung als die beiden anhänger hier
erhofft haben für diesen heutigen abend
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren